et bien la recette de la macaronade de
moules nous sommes allés la chercher
dans ce village de pêcheurs là-bas tout
à l'extrémité de la ville de sète et qui
s'appelle la pointe-courte la pointe
courte
en fait c'est un quartier de la ville de
sète mais un quartier qui a sa vie
propre
il a été bâti il ya 150 ans sur les
bords du canal qui relie le bassin de
dos à la méditerranée et rien n'a changé
depuis ou presque rien il continue
d'être habité à 95% par des pêcheurs qui
vont travailler sur l'étang de thau et
qui forment une véritable famille c'est
aussi le paradis des pêcheurs à la ligne
et deschamps qui profitent de l'aubaine
[Musique]
françois vrel est un enfant du pays
c'est un vrai pointu comme on les
appelle il est né dans ce village de la
pointe courte
tout comme sa femme nina qui n'a jamais
quitté les bords de l'étang de thau
françois brel aujourd'hui est à la
retraite mais il continue de donner la
manne à ses deux fils qui ont pris sa
relève dans la mytiliculture autrement
dit l'élevage des moules c'est madame
brel son épouse qui va nous montrer
comment on fait la macaronade de moules
à la pointe courte avec des moules bien
entendu que françois brel est allé
lui-même chercher dans le bassin de thau
expliquez vous ce que vous faites
largement décidé de mettre dès le matin
à kaboul au parti comme les moules il
faut les chercher
alors autant que possible il faut qu'il
soit très près alors ce qui fait que je
fais à le produire à charger le couteau
est ensuite envoyé avec il fallait le
faire
je les nettoie pour y lever espèce de
petit périple le kia sur le sur la
mousserie cette moule
on hamm est à écouter oui quand j'avais
saladier voilà il ne faut que la lame
ont été goûtés pour deux soirs de suite
on portera la part prendre et c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéresse c'est le
travail de l'homme et chercher le tarn
et de langues
pour le reste le programme à cesser le
travail la fin après l'achat par à faire
un mail à votre bel arrêt à mener à bien
l étape état devient on va les voir ce
qu'elle fait à l'intérieur de la maison
bonjour madame brown très bien alors
pendant que votre mari est en train de
préparer les boules
vous vous occupez de la farce mais grâce
aussi aux médailles du persil et mais
avec de la chapelure
voilà pour ma part c'est tout ça vous
l'avez déjà préparé et mélanger et tout
mélanger réa par six minutes
et on voit les moules il en rate les
laver et merci c'est un bon moyen de
vous faire quelque chose de bien on va
essayer alors dans cette farce
vous devriez remplissent chaque boule
chaque molière
11 mounaques officiel ah bon c'est pour
ça le film
voilà les faits les porteurs ayant une
bonne pour ne pas qu'ils t'aiment pas tr
pourquoi vous voulez boulot pour pâques
est sourde à la vacation et tout le
monde pensait de la même façon tout le
monde ficelles et les moules comme ça
avec du fil à coudre mais là c'est pas
mal du tout voilà voyons et nous
l'apprécions référé l'aimé comme ça
longtemps l'amour là nous voyez nous
allons pas légal de manière de ce
terrain alors une fois que toutes les
moules seront remplis de farce et bien
ficelé qu'est ce que vous allez faire
une foire aussi gelé aux hôtes de marque
à son rôle en aidant ses deux soeurs
seraient aussi remémoré je fais ma sauce
c'est là c'est pas difficile à faire est
un bras qui était l'homme l'amour a
besoin d'être bien pop
comprenez c'est un plat qui revient cher
non pas 30 de toujours des mollahs la
lecture de mon logis près je crois que
ça vaut aussi frein était lourd ouais
j'en fais 12,5
je crains que sur six heures à 335 de la
tomate heures la chair salée
il faut compter chaque de fresnes 60
francs pour deux kilos de moules et donc
pour 8 personnes à bord voilà je mets
damak et sorel maintenant que les moules
farcies mon coeur et je fais chauffer
mon nous lui il est chaud
[Applaudissements]
alors les moules ont frissonné pendant
cinq minutes à peu près et voulait
retirer provisoirement
alors maintenant c'est la sauce ça
c'était une partie donc tout à fait
distincte cher sa vie voilà la poitrine
ce n'est pas rien d'accord donc que vous
aller couper en petits d'entre nous a
ajouté il ya 2 oignons lendemain
[Musique]
combien vous en effet de concentrer deux
boîtiers de la can car oui et je vois
que deux militaires pourquoi il est
moins forte des oisillons et puis
qu'est-ce que vous ajoutez la des
primaires voilà pourquoi on en lit du
goût la partie du poivre c'est
indispensable le piment
vous remplissez vos quatre boîtes avec
de l'eau vers le lieu est devenu combien
d'eau au moulin
la deuxième opération
mettez la main mais nous l'avons bien
revenus à la sacem et ce sera très bien
dans sa cuisine là il faut des meilleurs
1,3 milliard entre une demi heure et les
trois quarts d'heure mais il faut que ça
pète
le goût et formation
bon eh bien pendant que ça ça cuit on va
les retrouver votre mari c'est vrai
pendant que sa cuisine avec ça mijote
j'aurais qu'on parle un peu de cette
macaronade c'est un plat qu'on commence
souvent ici la bonne soupe à la pointe
courte ça se mange froid et même
attentat ville de sète et beaucoup même
sur la région je sais que non seulement
c'est un très bon plage est une
spécialité avant mais à quelles
occasions ça se mange ça se mange en
famille alors vous savez des fois en
réunion de famille alors on dit être
malade et pendant que nous nous pensions
sur la culture des moules madame brel
quant à elle s'occupait des macaronis
que l'on fait cuire au dernier moment
inutile de vous dire comment on fait
cuire les macaronis bien entendu quand
il sent cuisine on les met dans un plat
on ajoute une couche de parmesan
on les recouvre ensuite de la sauce dans
laquelle ont baigné les moules farcies
[Musique]
on mélange le tout et on dispose les
moules sur un autre plan
[Musique]
voilà un travail très dur alors un
lettrage et ses treize ans déjà
on y va
c'est vrai il ya une façon de manger la
moule aussi bien alors il faut donc là
dépis l'est comme on aimerait faire
et alors comment comment on fait la
première des choses qu'on voit la main
guerroyer il faut enchaîner par ce côté
là où vous vous trouvez en saveurs dans
la moule oui ouais abondamment émeutes à
doha budget vous avez le puits qui se
défient à bord avant m
ficelé il faut la wave ou là où j'en
suis fier il a frappé la boule et vous
affichez vous d'accord voici la
construira sur la saveur d'un rouge
commence avec nous et puis j'aimerais
messieurs de la presse et après on a la
boule qu'il ya deux ans à venir
voilà pour aller chez joly qui s'est
agglomérée avec que ceux de aboulaye à
merveille ou des lieux
et
[Musique]